hi I'm Erik Bosse and the Batman movie
finally seems to be moving forward after
years of big updates about its
development now with Robert Pattinson
set to wear the cowl and incur the best
Twilight jokes for people who most
likely never watched any of the Twilight
movies give him a chance they play
baseball the Muse here I'm gonna explain
everything we know about this upcoming
Batman film and the clues that the
director is hinted at what the story
might be okay the Batman as it is still
tentatively titled
is scheduled to release about two years
from now on June 25th 2021 Matt Reeves
director of the to recent plan of the
apes movies Cloverfield
Let Me In this guy's awesome he is still
writing the script and he will direct
with principal production rumored to
begin in the early months of 2020 Robert
Pattinson was recently announced to play
Bruce Wayne whom Reeves is writing as a
30 year old character still in his early
years as the Caped Crusader and Gotham
City but not an origin story so do not
expect to see a fourth Thomas and Martha
Wayne murder there's only so many times
we can see those socialites and
philanthropist be murdered in front of a
little boy now the development process
for this film has been a story of delay
and restarts originally Ben Affleck was
going to star co-rect and direct a story
that was going to explore the mysterious
defaced Robin suit in the Batcave and
Batman V Superman suggesting to many of
us that the story could be some
adaptation of under the Red Hood delving
into the story of the Joker in Robin
Jeremy Irons was set to return as Alfred
and test footage hinted that Joe
Manganiello could appear as Deathstroke
indeed Deathstroke even showed up with
Lex Luthor in the post-credits scene
after Justice League but all those plans
stalled and Jesse Eisenberg's max landis
impersonation was dunzo I love people
together the mixed reviews and under
performance of Justice League led Warner
Brothers to reevaluate its whole DC film
future still in production titles like
Aquaman and Shazam obviously still came
out and so will the upcoming Joker in
one room in 1984 meanwhile the Batman
got delayed a sequel to Justice League
got scrapped and last we heard of the
flash movie
Ezra Miller said he was planning a
script rewrite and maybe when he's done
fixing the flash Miller can take a crack
at those fantastic beast movie scripts
yikes so while all of this was going on
Matt Reeves had been brought into
directs the Batman and rewrite Affleck
script so it was more in his new vision
and then after months and months of
speculation earlier this year a flake
officially announced he was stepping
down from the role leading to a few
weeks ago when Robert Pattinson was
announced as the new Batman
both he and Nicholas Hoult were
considered for the role and then they
both tried on a flex bat suit and
Pattinson was cast now Reeves says that
he intends this Batman film to be an
almost nor even detective version of
Batman inspired by the mystery Noirs of
Alfred Hitchcock it will reportedly only
connect to the DCU as we've known it in
very small limited ways if at all and
one source says that the story will be
set in 1990s because apparently it's
important that every superhero movie now
is now the speculation over who the
villains could be as is always the case
of Batman films has been wild and mostly
wrong probably reports on The Hollywood
Reporter have suggested that the penguin
and Catwoman could be featured as well
as a half dozen members of Gotham's
rogues gallery there's also been
speculation that villains like Firefly
and the Riddler could appear as well as
two-face and the Mad Hatter based on
rumors from Caspian notices at this
point it's hard to take any of these
rumors seriously because Reeves is still
working on the film's script and they
won't begin shooting it for at least 7
months a lot can change between now and
then but Reeves has given some
indication of which Batman stories he
might be looking to for inspiration
which ones are they and why might they
make an amazing Batman film but before I
continue thank you to petal for
sponsoring this episode so if you're
like me and you somehow stumbled into
adulthood with no credit score
whatsoever like you tried to sign a
lease and they're like I'm trying to
check your credit and somehow you don't
exist like it might be a ghost so yeah
if you're a credit googa ghost petal is
perfect for you it's a credit card to
help you build credit with zero fees
pete'll has partnered with Webb bank
member FDIC to provide access to a Visa
credit card and peddles cashback grows
with you earn 1% cash back right away
and 1.5% cash back when he make 12
monthly on-time payments and when peddle
says no fees they mean it no annual fees
no late payment fees no foreign
transaction fees or any other kind of
fees peddle actually suggests that you
pay in
full each month so you avoid interest
charges entirely and with pedals
auto-pay feature you will never forget
to make a payment
as of today they're variable APR 15
point twenty four percent to twenty six
point twenty four percent it's about
time a credit card company helped you
succeed financially so check out the
peddle credit card go to pedal card comm
slash new rockstars today to find out
more
that's peddle with the T pedal P et al
card comm slash new rock stars okay
let's break down which comic storylines
Matt Reeves has listed as favorites he
tweeted that he was into year one the
long Halloween dark victory and ego he
shouted out Neal Adams and the original
cane and finger stories saying that he
could go on let's work our way backwards
Bob Kane and Bill Finger of course
created the Batman character first
appearing in 1939 it was known at that
point for more lighthearted kid-friendly
adventures decades later Neal Adams
worked with Danny O'Neil and they
restored Batman's dark brooding
reputation after the Adam West years as
fun as those were they were known for
creating the character of Ra's al Ghul
and reestablishing characters like to
face in the Joker as the homicidal
maniacs that we know them to be the
story ego is an interesting title for
reads to mention it's set mostly in
Batman's mind with his identity shaken
by witnessing a suicide dividing into
his revenge hungry it represented by
Batman and his rational super-ego
represented by Bruce Wayne they debate
over whether to kill the Joker to stop
the source of Gotham's evils but
ultimately the identities merge and
swear never to kill perhaps Reeves
mentioned ego to suggest a shift from
Zack Snyder who has been quite defensive
of his decision to depict Batman as a
violent killer in his films meanwhile
the long Halloween and dark victory are
a part of the same series by Jeph Loeb
and Tim sail the long Halloween is
included in most filmmakers lists of top
influences because it's awesome and this
story got them is plagued by the holiday
killer who murders a new victim every
major holiday has Batman Commissioner
Gordon a newly elected District Attorney
Harvey Dent tried to maintain control in
the midst of a gang war between the
Falcone and Maroni crime families you
might recognize some parallels here with
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
which featured a similar focus on city
politics and policing matters Nolan's
Batman Begins also drew heavily on
Batman year one another favorite Reeves
mentioned Frank Miller's year one is
another hugely influential story arc but
again since Reeves film won't be an
origin story I think we could rule it
out as a direct adaptation there have
been many other popular Batman comics
long favored to be adapted for film
there's the hush storyline featuring a
bandaged villain behind a plot to
manipulate a number of major DC figures
actually a trailer for the DC animated
version of hush just came out that will
come out later this summer
there's also Grant Morrison's gothic be
training mysteries surrounding the
villain mr. whisper the story has a dark
religious tone and a literal deal with
the devil it's crazy good Matt Reeves is
also cited filmmaker Alfred Hitchcock
famous for his mystery thrillers known
for their surreal trips into the human
psyche psycho explored the idea of a
murderer being revealed as another
character split identity vertigo is a
famous detective more about
psychological obsession with enigmatic
love interests perhaps a basis for a
version of Batman obsessed with figures
like Catwoman poison ivy maybe even the
ultimate enigma figure the Riddler
Hitchcock's spellbound is set in a
mental hospital with psycho analysts
questioning the realities and identities
there's a trippy dream sequence
contributed by surrealist artist
Salvador Dali I'd love to see Reeves
Batman story set in Arkham like the
games which could explain why so many of
the rogue's gallery villains are
speculated to appear in this film which
storyline would you like to see adapted
for this upcoming Matt Reeves Robert
Pattinson Batman film comment down below
with your thoughts follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at ei vas and
subscribe to new rock stars but the
latest updates on all the films you're
most excited about thanks for joining me
and I'm gonna rejoin Team Edward
vampire baseball
[Music]